let's talk about one of the best nutrients for
improving your thinking and that would be choline
now choline was once considered one of the
b vitamins but now it's considered kind of
a standalone vitamin but choline which by the way
is a kind of a lemon tasting vitamin you can even
suck on them and they taste like a little lemon
drop it's a required nutrient by your body because
it's a primary building block of something called
acetylcholine which is a neurotransmitter for your
brain neurotransmitters work like hormones
but instead of traveling through the blood
they travel through the nervous system
so it's involved in communication as
improving new memories it's involved in certain
processes that influence reasoning concentration
focus cognition which is understanding things
sleep growing synapses in your brain cells
and coordinating movements especially movements
involving speed and accuracy and there's some
really interesting research on this i'm going to
put it down below of people taking choline and
noticing some significant improvements in these
right here now if you're deficient in choline
you have a tendency to get brain fog you have
problems with the tension and focus you can even
develop brain fatigue decreased ability to learn
things memory loss poor recall get distracted
easily which is part of this right here and
becoming irritable other than that you'll
be pretty good now the question is where would
you get choline in your diet number one source
beef liver just 2.4 ounces will give you 290
milligrams shrimp is a good source of choline
4 ounces provide 153 milligrams but just one egg
will give you 146 milligrams i personally consume
a lot of eggs and then we have scallops four
ounces of scallops will give you 125 milligrams
now there's a lot of other foods that will provide
choline including even leafy greens but these
are probably the best sources right here and so
if you have some of these symptoms right here
and you want to improve these and you're starting
to consume these foods or even taking colon as a
supplement and it doesn't work there's something
else that is a requirement to make sure this works
and that is making sure that your diet
is correct you're avoiding certain things
that deplete choline and for that information i
put a link down below if you're new to my channel
to know exactly how to do that thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the US hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help